what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we cover the origins and powers of the
strongest characters and comics and for
whatever reason that i will never fully
understand you guys have been asking me
to make a video on simon williams wonder
man i mean he's powerful but i never
really expected someone to be like hey
rob you know who would make a great
beyond omega level video wonder man like
i i just i never really i never really
saw that coming so wonder man was
created by stan lee jack kirby and don
heck and first appeared in the avengers
number nine in 1964. now simon williams
is the son of a wealthy arms
manufacturer and inherits his father's
company however his company begins to
see a downturn in business because of
the success of stark industries and so
simon begins embezzling money from his
business but gets caught convicted and
then thrown in jail now he's bailed out
of jail by amor the enchantress and then
begins working for baron heinrich zemo
who wants to use simon's anger at tony
stark to convince him to undergo a
transformation into a super villain that
will battle the avengers now simon
agrees and zemo uses ionic energy to
imbue him with superpowers and gives him
the nickname wonderman now wonderman is
said to infiltrate the avengers with
instructions to betray them during a
battle with zemo's masters of evil which
included the enchantress and scourge the
execution but in order to make sure
wonder man goes along with the plan zemo
tells him that the ionic energy he was
exposed to will kill him if he does not
regularly take a drug that only zemo has
access to now when push comes to shove
however wonder man sides with the
avengers against zemo and is apparently
killed in the same issue he debuted in
because he doesn't get the antidote from
zima but following his apparent death
hank pym records his brain waves just in
case he can be brought back to life and
simon's brother eric gets mad at the
avengers and becomes a super villain
known as grim reaper who you've probably
heard of grim reaper was okay uh well he
was actually more than okay he was
pretty cool but he was cool for the time
but as it turns out wonder man was not
actually dead he was just in a coma and
was kept in a state of suspended
animation during which time ultron stole
simon's brain waves that had been
recorded by hank pym in case he could be
revived and then uses them to create
vision but wonder man would also be
revived on a few different occasions
albeit temporarily first he was revived
by kane the conqueror in avengers number
131 to battle the avengers as part of
king's legion of the unliving which was
a group of dead characters that he
pulled from the timeline from a point
before their deaths but eventually the
legion break free of king's control and
are sent back to their appropriate time
streams next wonder man would be revived
by his brother the grim reaper and a
really obscure villain named the black
talon and would once again fight the
avengers and so after going back into
suspended animation wonder man is
finally revived permanently by the
living laser who hypnotizes him into
attacking the avengers yet again but
finally in control of his own thoughts
wonder man fights and defeats his
brother and then eventually becomes a
full-time member of the avengers before
moving to hollywood to pursue an acting
career where he helps found the west
coast avengers now as for wonder man's
powers they stem from the ionic energy
he was exposed to by berenzema which
gave him super human physical attributes
including strength durability speed and
reflexes wonder man's strength is
probably the attribute he's best known
for and in his initial appearance his
strength level is said to be comparable
to thor's in fact that was later
confirmed by hercules after wonder man
punches him through a wall in fact
wonder man was able to knock thor off
his feet with one of his punches and did
the same thing to hank him when he was
giant man now wonder man was also able
to defeat some ridiculously strong
characters like carol danvers
abomination red hulk the thing and
neymar he also demonstrates inability to
hold up 50 000 tons and has also thrown
a cree spacecraft and battled the hulk
to a stalemate so even though he isn't a
character that gets a lot of attention
he's absolutely one of the strongest
characters in marvel comics and in fact
captain america stated that wonder man's
strength was at the same level as that
of the century now if you're familiar
with the city at all you know just how
big of a statement that is and if you
aren't familiar with the century we just
did a beyond omega level video on him so
you can basically go check that out now
in addition to his immense strength
wonder man also has insane durability he
survived a bomb that blew up after he
swallowed it yes you heard that
correctly he swallowed a bomb and then
it exploded he was also punched into the
core of a planet by gladiator and
although it did knock him out he
recovered after a short time he's also
survived the explosion of missiles
punches from savage hulk energy blast
from the silver surfer and a punch from
the century now originally wonder man
could fly but only with the assistance
of an ionic jetpack provided to him by
zema but eventually he learned to better
control his ionic abilities and was able
to channel them to allow himself to fly
and he's able to fly at extremely fast
speeds and is confirmed to be able to
travel at 400 miles per hour now wonder
man is also effectively immortal and is
able to come back to life each time he
dies which has been around six times
since he was introduced and every time
he does so he is seemingly more powerful
than he was prior to his death now
although zemo's experiment on wonder man
was merely supposed to make him equal to
any avenger in terms of strength what it
actually did was turn him into a being
of pure ionic energy because of this not
only is he able to fly he also does not
need food water or air to survive
another aspect of wonder man's energy
powers is that he can manipulate his
ionic energy into powerful beams from
his hands or eyes and can also change
the physical size and shape of his body
as time goes on wonder man learns to use
his powers in new ways including the
ability to lend energy to others and
reabsorb it back into himself and also
the ability to teleport now wonder man's
also a skilled hand-to-hand combatant
having trained with captain america
however after a falling out with the
avengers over the superhuman
registration act simon vowed to stop
solving his problems through fighting
and only rejoined the avengers on the
condition that he would help them
through his public relations skills and
not his prowess in battle even so when
the avengers were faced with battling a
celestial wonder man allows rogue to
absorb his powers to battle it but she
ends up absorbing his consciousness as
well and he remains trapped in rogue's
mind for a while which i mean you
thought he would have seen that coming
right like never touch rogue but he was
only freed when rogue kissed deadpool
and absorbed his healing factor which
allowed wonder man's body to be restored
but even after his return wonder man
remains committed to pacifism so despite
being one of the strongest characters in
the marvel universe it's not likely
we're going to see him put his powers on
display anytime soon unless the marvel
cinematic universe decides to put him in
a movie but that's one of the things
that we're trying to do with this series
right bring attention to characters that
often just don't get the attention that
they're due based on how powerful that
they are i never would have known how
powerful wonder man was i mean look
here's the thing guys i knew of wonder
man but wonder man's one of those
characters where like as far as i was
concerned he exists and he did some
things and they don't really talk about
him anymore and now we are here and like
that's it right i mean it's just he's a
guy who did stuff like i never cared
about wonder man like it was he was
never really relevant to me man but
after this dude this guy is legit dude i
love wonder man like this this is
ridiculous i need to read more stories
about wonder man thank you guys for
telling me to do this video about simon
williams i was a little unsure why would
wonder man be beyond omega level right
like this guy sucks like he's got like
sunglasses and he and he has really
really good people skills right beyond
omega level the ability to hang out with
people and start a conversation like
it's just that seemed like all it really
was but like man this guy is amazing so
if you enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace